les
nouvelles salles d'attentes aménagés
dans des roulottes c'est un des nombreux
symptômes de la crise qui frappe
l'hôpital de mont laurier
le personnel est exaspéré tellement
qu'on nous offre une visite guidée de
l'hôpital en ce 19 avril le taux
d'occupation des civières de l'urgence
est de 240 % l'encombrement est
manifeste entre des piles de matériel
des patients comme michel bolduc victime
d'un malaise cardiaque besoin d'un
adulte sur mes manques de pêcheurs faute
de personnel on a dû transférer les
soins intensifs dans l'urgence s'est pas
trop posé s'il arrive sur une cassette
innovant ville lumière l'environnement
est inapproprié pour les patients des
soins intensifs et l'équipement
inadéquat
pour un
siège deux ans faute de toilettes
standard ici on fait ce qu'on peut avec
ce que l'on a pourtant un étage
au-dessus on découvre lanciers
département de soins intensifs
cinq chambres rénovées mais complètement
vide a fait qu'on nous a donné comme
explication c'est les 60 ans on peut pas
rouler les soins intensifs par manque de
personnel un peu plus loin d'autres lits
cette fois d'hospitalisation tout aussi
vide je pense qu permis on eu 38 ou 40
lits et on a baissé cet été jusqu'à 28
lire je sais pas ce même moins que ce
faute de personnel la source du problème
est le départ de dizaines d'infirmières
au cours des derniers mois la direction
affirme que le recrutement est plus
difficile qu'ailleurs au québec
d'antoine-labelle c'est le secteur qui
vieillit le plus vite au québec un
vieillissement accéléré donc peu de
jeunes pour prendre la relève
en plus de la pénurie d'infirmières
mont-laurier manque de médecins
spécialistes
[Musique]
sont désertés tout l'équipement
d'ophtalmologie est au rancart faute
d'ophtalmologistes le 6 promet une
solution l'automne prochain mais
plusieurs autres spécialités et coop on
manque de médecins spécialistes quatre
des cinq psychiatres des hautes
laurentides son parti le service en
pneumologie est inexistant la pédiatrie
a récemment disparu difficile de retenir
les spécialistes dans les hautes
laurentides
puis en termes de médecins spécialistes
n'a cessé en et noir exemple en
radiologie on avait deux postes ont eu
des difficultés à combler on il a comblé
les deux jeunes ont acquis par la région
veut reprendre en main le recrutement le
sentiment c'est d'être complètement
abandonné c'est vraiment un à bordeaux
bien des décideurs et médecins estiment
que le sis des laurentides laisse tomber
la région je pense qu'on ne considère
comme une société de deuxième classe
comme plusieurs médecins de la région
luc laurin dénonce la centralisation
forcé par la réforme barrettes de 2015
faudrait peut-être décentraliser les
pouvoirs et dans la même
décentralisation de regarder la
particularité d'une région comme la
nôtre dans cette région vieillissante
entre l'abitibi et montréal le sentiment
d'abandon est répandue thierno peau de
notre riche pour parce qu on est loin
qu'on est vieux qu'eux on n'a pas de
regret ou soit senti ici david gêne-t-il
et radio-canada mont laurier